well in other news were learning more  about some of the eight Americans killed  in the crash 24-year old Samuel sumo of  Sheffield Massachusetts was working for  a global health organization she was  headed to her first assignment in Kenya  and Uganda brothers Bennett and Melvin  riffle from Redding California were on a  world adventure before the birth of  Melvin's daughter in May  Melvin's wife Brittany had been with  them but returned home after visiting  Australia while the brothers continued  traveling we spoke with Melvin's friends  who say they will do everything possible  to support his wife and the baby a lot  of new uncles every one of us will be  here for long  everything about him he's the most  loving most joyful most positive person  I've ever had the pleasure knowing a lot  of new uncle's stepping up family and  friends came together yesterday at a  reading church to remember the brothers  a GoFundMe page is raising funds to help  Melvin's wife and baby